die Politik kümmert sich um lauter
Themen die total uninteressant sind also
gender interessierte natürlich
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das sind alles
Themen ehrlich gesagt da kann man drüber
reden da gibt es auch Gründe drüber zu
reden aber die Leute interessiert das 0
und das heißt wir haben eine
gesellschaftspolitische Debatte im Land
die völlig an den Menschen vorbei geht
und wir haben eine Politik die den
Beweis nicht mehr führt dass sie die
großen Probleme unseres Landes wirklich
löst und das macht die Leute die
Menschen haben Abstiegsängste und die
Menschen sind stark verunsichert weil
dieses System scheinbar nicht mehr in
der Lage ist die großen Herausforderung
zu lösen und das ist eine ganz
gefährliche Mischung und ich bin ganz
bei Ihnen über diese Themen müssen wir
reden und wir müssen gar nicht über die
AFD reden oder möglichst wenig über die
reden
[Musik]